that's nothing will do nothing people
blow that in the weekend $10,000 is
nothing twenty thirty thousand
generational change a hundred thousand
dollars may not be enough and then if
you don't know anything if you're not
educated you know anything about
finances one hundred thousand dollars
gonna last you would I don't know for
months I've had a friend that had two
million I think he got two million
dollars from the settlement blew it all
have nothing to show for it and that's
not what they just giving somebody money
it's not gonna help them at all people
get too caught up in the name flex it
right I know that this is I know that
the name is it means a lot obviously
because the moment is named after but
but the biggest freedom when I see
blacks I see freedom some people see
blacks they see all you hate the
Democrat it's really not much to do with
the Democratic race more of being free
having a free mind there's something
else out there we for the longest we
feel like it's only one thing now that
we have that we can utilize or access we
just want people to know let me show you
the history of what we've been doing all
this time and it's gotten us nowhere
here is another perspective think about
this for a minute I believe most black
people are conservative most my people
conservative believe it or not even
black criminals are conservative all you
gotta do is think about it for a few
seconds if you were to sell drugs so
drug dealers I have some of my family
cannot confirm it a knife they still
doing it you have drug dealer selling
weed a neighbor drug dealer they won't
government intervention never drug
didn't want to pay taxes on it on most
drug dealers a libertarian dealer that's
like hey man you wouldn't hustling all
week and putting your life on the line
maybe you were sick that day
let me give all my drug money and split
it with you is it fair it's never gonna
happen
naima drug bill they don't have a gun
that don't want their right to bear arms
you know per se to protect themselves
and I know it's a weird analogy but I
think that it resonates because in the
community those things are not just the
criminal element of it but the
conservative ideas right so give me a
wider example than just the black people
as their criminal that's widen that a
little bit right so would you meet on
social issues though sure about this
most religious people
I think per capita is black folks we go
to church every Sunday we shout and
cares
maduk churches women we with those
Scripture at you in a minute we are the
most conservative culturally in my
opinion at least growing up we were that
way my dad didn't let you make excuses
what do you mean you want somebody to
hand something to you you better work
for what you got my dad started at 18
years old on fire department now he's
the chief
my dad didn't put up with that it's
unacceptable you don't want to be a
coward you're a strong man these are the
things that grandfather's used to say to
and a lot of people in a black community
still have remnants of that grandma a
strong grandma used to say you see the
hail of jail if you want to act like
that and sell drugs and be that way
black people adhere to that idea the
structure of self rx a entrepreneurs
have been an individual think about
music think about culture black people
dominate culture because we created a
unique idea on our own in many ways that
is that is more a big conservative idea
we don't want to be followers we don't
want people telling us what to do
we've always pushed the envelope as a
community that's to me more of a
conservative idea look at the
entrepreneurs going from drug dealing to
being billionaires jay-z and all these
other people who took advantage of
saying you can turn your life around and
you could be an entrepreneur you can
make it as high as you want to Oprah
Winfrey you can keep naming them I'll
tell you one that people really don't
talk about is its madam CJ Walker who's
the first female millionaire out of any
race in the light in the early 1900's
millionaire they got pictures of her
with white people driving around in the
early 1900s so we have always understood
the entrepreneurial spirit and for some
reason we believe that the Democrats are
their side instead of the Republicans
and we've been confused in my opinion so
back to bless it if we only understood I
think we would change we've seen we've
seen people do you feel it breaking I
think because the other thing I said
you're right before we started was the
day that all the Democrats started
talking about reparations
I called candidates and I said this is
cuz of you yes she caused such a
freaking split where it where it needed
to happen that suddenly the Democrats
are like alright guys we're sorry about
some cash stay with us here the whole
cold hard cash and what's the number
that's the other thing it's like there's
never gonna be a number that's enough
right yeah you know yeah it's because
reparation themself is the stupidest
idea ever because how you gonna pay it
we pay taxes still the thing on not
let's pay taxes I'm gonna pay for my own
reparations if I was if I were to get it
think about this how much money are they
gonna give you well they'll tell you
they'll tell you that they're gonna take
it from billionaires oh yeah give you
how much though that's not gonna do
nothing people blow that in the weekend
ten thousand dollars is nothing twenty
thirty thousand generational change a
hundred thousand dollars may not be
enough and then if you don't know
anything if you're not educating you
anything about finances one hundred
thousand dollars gonna last you would I
don't know for months I've had a friend
that had two million I think she got two
million dollars from a settlement blew
it all I'm done to show for it and
that's not what they just giving
somebody money it's not gonna help them
at all but that's this well and also it
never would be enough not just the
literal amount but like okay so let's
say you gave every black person fifty
thousand dollars just pick up a number
well now your two generations past that
right and if the left just keeps going
off the deep end their grandchildren ago
wait you sold us out for 50 grand true
that was nothing true you know it's just
in its almost the reverse of the way
human psychology actually works right
and then you know you know everybody
knows when you give a person something
you just hand somebody some they don't
appreciate it as much what kind of
growth potential give me a better
education I don't need reparations and
money fix these dollar old schools with
the money we already given you I mean
this seems like common sense to me so
you do you see do you think going 20/20
and you're obviously a Trump guy yeah do
you think there's gonna be just a
seriously massive shift in the black
vote I think it's gonna be a shift in
the black vote I'm not sure how much the
turnout is gonna be if that makes sense
I think a lot of people are leaving a
Democratic Party I think that's the
biggest threat to them is that people
may not be on Trump training yet all
right Trump Trump is like on a SWAT team
where you have the RAM the first person
bank to the doors shards going
everywhere it's chaos you throwing
flashbangs in there everything is
confusing and then the people that come
in and smooth after him
Trump is causing a lot of the ruckus I
believe that you may see more of it
after Trump the residual effect of what
he has done it you have more people
actually going to vote because
it is still a scary moment for black
folks to even say they support Trump
people like me know what you're gonna do
to me people are over Trump's about
sounding what they're gonna do they're
not gonna fight me and that's not gonna
form so they don't say stuff to people
like myself but if you live in a family
whatever it's very difficult but what I
will say is that when I first started
doing things about the same time Candace
did me hurt meant when she was repealed
black mhm and you know Pete it was like
ninety ten maybe black folks are racing
on my page I mean very many less than
that now it's like 60/40 there's so many
black people in box just flood in my
inbox saying dude you woke me up I can't
say nothing my mom and they would kill
me last year like it was just something
I had to call it a kids parent on the
phone because she didn't want her son to
go cuz it was conservative thing I said
man get a boy chance let him let him go
and she ended up letting him go to the
event but when he got home they
criticized and family wanted his dad
yeah I helped them get prepared for they
have a speech with his dad his dad one
have a sit-down with him like you know
how to be a man yeah if they wanted to
sit down and talk about Trump yeah it
was just the weirdest thing ever but I
have to prepare for it but it's very
difficult but if you look at any of the
pose you know like I mean people mean
I'm not a real poor guy cuz they say hey
Hillary winning and I know she was gonna
lose and she lost but you can have
somewhat of an indication of what people
are thinking on the side of saying that
about 20% on Fox did one around 20%
the n-double-a-cp did one that people
never talk about around 20% and I think
Rasmussen around 30% what about that
moment during the State of the Union
when Trump talked about all-time low
black unemployment and they showed the
picture like are the Congressional Black
Caucus and nobody applauded it was so I
don't know how other people felt but to
me it really almost made tears to my mom
yeah disgusting it's like why don't we
hate each other so much I'm not wild a
hate the progression of black people so
much you'll hate you're all people so
much and that's how I see it well they
wouldn't need a caucus much banger you
know Chris Rock cops need a certain
amount of crime which I know is probably
a little touchy for you but like every
group every group needs a little
something to stay in business
and they know that they're gonna go out
of business actually we stopped worrying
about what what race people are right
and double AC P all these other
organizations are gonna bigger than that
you know al sharpton holiday will be
unemployed yeah yeah you know so but
they need to do these things but it
hurts people it it hurts them and it
helps people that's on my side because
all I can do is point to them and say if
anything whether you disagree you like
them or not when you say that black
people are having the expression of
historic low unemployment at least do
this at least we like right can we get a
snap maybe something you sitting on your
hands with listen they are not a
representation of our ancestors Martin
Luther King would it would be rolling in
his grave sofa he'd be catching on fire
he'd be rolling so hard these people are
evilness to our community if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell